okay let's get right into audience
questions for the week first one is hey
David we've seen all sorts of different
takes and plans from Donald Trump to
governor's about how and when states
should start to reopen after the virus
what should a reasonable reopening
America plan look like so a couple
things on this number one I don't have
any independent knowledge in the sense
that I believe we should trust medical
experts and public health experts on
this and so I'm going by what those
individuals are saying not by what
politicians are saying I think there's
one other element to this that's
important in an ideal world we would
have done sort of like a full shutdown
probably around February 20 it could
have gone to four months and it would
have been over this week and we would be
in much better shape right now hindsight
is 20/20 but the point is there's a
limited political willingness to
continue expending political capital as
the protests mount and the demands mount
as crazy as the demands of the
protesters are as irrelevant as those
demands are to public health issues the
reality is the pressure is going to grow
and it's not going to be possible to
open nothing so I'm starting from the
point of not what is or would have been
the safest but what makes sense given
that the pressure to reopen at least
parts of society it will only continue
to grow number one is testing now I'm
not going to get into the full back and
forth about how Donald Trump initially
took took credit for testing even though
the testing was terrible he would insist
that it's all him now that it's clear
the testing is not up to par to reopen
Trump is saying governor's have to
figure out this testing thing let's
ignore the shirking of responsibilities
for a moment we don't have enough
testing we need at a bare minimum
500,000 tests a day most roadmaps say we
need more including like a million tests
today remember that with a million tests
a day still takes you almost a year to
test everybody one roadmap says we need
22 million tests a day so you can test
everybody on a rolling 14 day roughly
basis certainly
500 or 600 thousand tests a day must be
in place but not only that you need
proper contact tracing infrastructure in
Massachusetts here they've been hiring
work from home contact tracers different
health systems have been doing it I
think it pays around $25 an hour work
from home all states need to be hiring
proper contact tracers so that you
increase testing as you test a lot of
people as soon as you get a positive
test contact tracer comes in and lets
individuals that may have been in
contact with that infected person know
so that they can quarantine then all the
stuff about phases I'm not gonna go
piece by piece through Donald Trump's
proposal because I've already done it
but a few thoughts on that number one
there won't be a light switch that's
flipped and we are back on some of the
earlier things that should happen
include what retail elements can start
to be opened up somewhat so that they
can recover some of their revenue
remember we've got the Paycheck
protection plan but the money ran out so
there's a ton of restaurants and other
retail facing businesses that risk going
completely out of business what can be
done in restaurants in terms of can
people sit at tables out back very much
spaced out so that they feel like
they've had a dining experience but the
bag of food is placed on the table as if
it were takeout there's no interaction
with the waitstaff would that make
people feel as though we're moving in
the right direction even though in
practice it wouldn't change that much
about the risk exposure I don't know I'm
just sort of thinking out loud here
schools this semester should not reopen
it just doesn't make any sense
we should focus on shooting for the fall
but being prepared to do the fall online
people who can work from home and who
work office jobs where a lot of the work
is email and phones should not go back
to work anytime soon we should keep as
many people home as is possible to lower
the risk of loosening up some of the
public elements gyms
probably can't open right away I know
that that was included in phase one of
trumps plan does not seem reasonable
seems like just a an absolute cesspool
of germs and even if you maintain social
distancing and
I don't see how you you avoid gyms
becoming a center of spread while we
have cases and we probably can't really
loosen travel anytime soon either so for
me the the immediate loosening x' would
be we start to let people get back to
being a little bit social ideally what
we're talking about is you know a couple
that's been self isolating and another
couple that's been self isolating get
together in a house and everybody you
don't shake hands but you can hang out a
couple of hours that probably would be
like a next step as cases go down again
some of these things of you know maybe
restaurants could figure out a way if
they're large enough you reduce the
capacity by 80 percent and you let
people without table service just sit
and have their takeout in the restaurant
these are the types of things that that
need to happen and then we want to start
opening up some other retail type
businesses that may have been closed but
again remember many of those have been
open a lot of stuff hasn't actually been
closed it's just been diminished and
people are having to you know wear masks
when they are inside but those are some
of the first steps I see but really the
steps that need to happen before
anything is actually opened is testing
that needs to increase dramatically and
contact tracing needs to increase them
dramatically until we have that opening
is a real risk